[Music]
since our last update we've made great
progress and the regeneration areas at
the end of November the much-anticipated
hypoid dog park opened its gates to the
public the ribbon was cut by Mayor Dan
Gordon and former resident Barbara
Townsend who lived on the land where the
park is located
dozens of four-legged locals joined the
celebration with prizes awarded to mr.
cowboy musk hiya boy be stressed scruffy
and wedgies tale following a short delay
due to the lockdown
the roading in the surrounding area has
now been upgraded Charles Street now
incorporates what used to be jolly
Street that has been resurfaced and
includes a new footpath and parking over
at norman kirk park the Cass Street car
park is also quickly taking shape
during the last couple of months the
grass for the sports grounds has
established well irrigation has been
installed and work on the softball
diamonds is now underway construction is
also about to start on the changing
rooms and public toilets they're due to
be completed in October in all going
well we'll see the sports fields in use
over the coming summer on the kuiper
River a second round of dredging is
underway after removing the remaining
high points by the Williams Street
bridge the barge will move downriver to
deal with silk buildup and further
improve navigability for vessels the
walkway between the Williams Street
Bridge and true solo park is also
receiving final repairs once complete
the popular teaming sculpture will
return following its removal after the
earthquakes
[Music]